[Musica]
la neve che cade su di te ma sopra
tutto con la tua pelle
anche il canottaggio meridionale per la Cina
mano nella mano con la lingua
e scusa per oggi lútea
Y
è che sanno di te che non sempre entrano
Mi disse
Ho sentito dove sono
Ora c'è di più
vogliono morire
chiaramente non ha più un buon odore
[Musica]
Tu vuoi essere
c'è una vigilia
un tesoro
se lo voglio se è di un amico
dei socialisti
tutti mi avvertono
e i mezzi di altri tempi che io no
Stavo andando a ballare
con quel selvaggio fornés via terra
[Musica]
vertice
[Applausi]
[Musica]
il libretto come si vede nel libro totale
è
Mi sono vestito per piangere
[Musica]
e non lui
entità
la schiena rimango
Ti tengo per mano e al lato santo
cristiano
se è un tremore di vetro
[Musica]
Signori
in passato è successo
io non sono
se non lo sono
che lo ha portato intero
hanno trionfato
più
padre
e in gennaio
l'ex uomo è
[Musica]
e destino